.
AND IT'S UP TO YOU NEW YORK.
AND THAT'S THE ANGLE.
JOINING ME NOW IS NEW YORK
CONGRESSMAN LEE ZELDIN,
CONGRESSMAN.
WHAT IS THE FIRST AND THAT YOU
WOULD DO TO REVERSE THIS
DOWNWARD SPIRAL, IF YOU WERE TO
BE ELECTED GOVERNOR?
>> DAY ONE WE SHOULD FIRE
MANHATTAN DISTRICT ATTORNEY
ALVIN.
THAT WILL SET THE, THEY SHOULD
BE ENFORCING THE LAW PUT OUT A
MEMO SAYING THAT HE WAS AND CAN
ENFORCE LAWS ACROSS THE BOOKS.
OTHERS SAID THAT HE WAS GOING TO
DOWNGRADE WHICH IS HE ON DAY ONE
THAT HE HAS FIRED.
THAT IS WITHIN THE
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY IN
NEW YORK FOR THE GOVERNOR OF THE
STATE.
I BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD REPEAL.
JUDGES SHOULD HAVE REGRESSION TO
PAST CRIMINAL RECORD AND
SERIOUSNESS OF THE OFFENSE ON
ALL OFFENSES.
PEOPLE NEED TO FEEL SAFE ON OUR
STREETS AND OUR SUBWAYS.
PEOPLE ARE LOOKING AT OTHER
STATES WITH HER MONEY WILL GO
FURTHER IT WILL FEELS SAFER AND
LIVE LIFE FULLER THEIR FLEA
NEW YORK AND NOT LOOKING BACK.
WE NEED TO DECLARE ON THE FIRST
DAY THAT PARENTS ARE BACK IN
CHARGE OF THEIR KIDS EDUCATION.
THE ATTACKS NEED TO STOP.
NEED TO START SAFELY EXTRACTING
OUR OWN NATURAL RESOURCES AND
APPROVING A PIPELINE
APPLICATIONS BRING SPENDING
UNDER CONTROL.
THE LIST GOES ON OF STUFF TO DO
BUT AS YOU POINTED OUT IN YOUR
QUESTION IT'S ABOUT WHAT YOU
GONNA DO ON DAY ONE.
WHAT CAN YOU DO WHEN YOU FIRST
GET THERE.
NOT LOOKING OVER THE COURSE OF
THE FIRST TERM.
SEE WHAT IF THE OF THE GROUND
RUNNING.
>> Laura: GOVERNOR GAVE NEXT
DONATION ABOUT WHAT HER REFORM
TO THE DISASTROUS BAIL REFORM
WILL BE IN THE NEW BUDGET WATCH.
>> PEOPLE NEED PROTECTIONS AND
WE BELIEVE THAT THESE
COMMON SENSE WERE NOT DOING
ANYTHING CRAZY.
SOME OF THE WEAKNESSES.
WE'LL GIVE YOU A CHANCE TO
DISSECT AND UNDERSTAND ALL THAT
WRITTEN UP TILL NOT TOO LONG
AGO.
>> Laura: I WOULDN'T CHOOSE
HER TO PICK A FIRST GRADE
PLAYGROUP DOWN THE ROAD.
SHE SOUNDS COMPLETELY CLUELESS.
THEY TINKERED A LITTLE BIT WITH
THE JUDGE'S DISCRETION IN ASKING
AND REQUIRING BAIL FOR CERTAIN
SUSPECTS WITH THE GUN HISTORY I
GUESS.
BUT THAT'S ABOUT IT.
THEY DIDN'T MAKE ANY REAL
SUBSTANTIAL REFORMS TO THE
BATTER FORM.
>> SHE SAID REALLY NOTHING.
THE STARTING POINT WE WERE ALL
CALLING FOR THIS AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE BUDGET PROCESS.
SHE SAID THAT SHE NEEDED TO SEE
MORE DATA.
ONCE YOU ADD UP THE PRESS
CLIPPINGS SOMEONE RELEASED ON AN
ARSON AND REARRESTED ON A DOUBLE
MANSLAUGHTER.
SOMEONE RELEASED ON BAIL AND THE
MURDERER 93-YEAR-OLD IN
SYRACUSE.
USE YOUR DATA YOU ADD UP ALL THE
CLIPPINGS.
YOU WANT TO FOCUS ON ILLEGAL
FIREARMS THERE IS A CONVERSATION
TO BE HAD FINE.
BUT WHEN SOMEONE IS PUSHED INTO
AN ONCOMING SUBWAY CAR AND THEY
LOSE THEIR LIFE.
SOMEONE STABBED TO DEATH IN
LOWER MANHATTAN.
THEIR PUNCH BECAUSE HER ASIAN
ORDER WEARING A YARMULKE FOR
THEIR SEEK IN A CAB DRIVER.
IF SO IS BEING KNIFED OUTSIDE OF
AN APARTMENT OR SMALL BUSINESSES
BEING BOOTED ALL OF THESE CRIMES
HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH GUNS.
>> Laura: WE KNOW HOW TO FIX
THIS.
IT'S BEEN DONE BEFORE.
THERE'S OTHER CITIES IN AMERICA
THEY'RE NOT AS DANGEROUS AS
NEW YORK SOME ARE MORE
DANGEROUS.
BUT THEY DID APPROACH IS THE
RIGHT WAY.
LITTLE CRIME HAS TO BE ENFORCED.
IF YOU DON'T ENFORCE LITTLE
CRIME EVERYTHING GOES.
AND RIGHT NOW THE CRIMINALS HAVE
THE RUN OF THE STREETS OF
NEW YORK.
A LEG UP POLICE THAT.
BUT THEY HAVE THE RUN OF THE
STREETS AND HOMELESSNESS IS A
GIANT, GIANT PROBLEM.
I DON'T THINK THE REPUBLICANS
SHOULD EVER GIVE UP ON NEW YORK
OR NEW ENGLAND.
THESE ARE IMPORTANT STATES WI